l'état d'urgence sanitaire a été
prolongée d'un mois dans un pays
désormais divisée en deux les autorités
ont décidé d'opter pour un allègement de
certaines mesures dans la zone la moins
touchée où se trouvent les petites et
moyennes communes les grandes villes
marocaines resteront elles soumises aux
restrictions de déplacement dont le
non-respect passible d'un à trois mois
d'incarcération avec moins de 9000 cas
est de 111 décès le pays a plutôt été
épargné par la pandémie certains
marocains tentent de faire preuve de
sagesse
d'autres demandes au gouvernement
d'assouplir le confinement dans les
régions les plus peuplées les commerces
commencent à reprendre la dynamique
aussi mais nous devons être prudents
pour pouvoir sortir de cette pandémie il
faut de la prudence on ne veut pas plus
de dégâts
les décisions des autorités qui sont
dans notre intérêt est dans l'intérêt de
tout le maroc
nous les appliquerons c'est l'été les
gens sentent la pression ils ne peuvent
plus supporter on peut encore tenir mais
nos enfants veulent sortir aller à la
plage ils se sentent prisonniers à la
maison les autorités doivent trouver une
solution
comme autoriser les enfants à sortir
quatre heures par jour il ya des
solutions
alors que le gouvernement a multiplié
les rétro pédalage
les inquiétudes sont désormais
nombreuses concernant le volet
économique les salariés redoutent des
licenciements massifs tandis que les
entrepreneurs se disent au bord du
gouffre financier enfin concernant les
32000 marocain toujours bloqués à
l'étranger
les promesses de rapatriement annoncés
n'ont pour l'instant pas été tenues